Prince Charles is going to continue
giving the couple at least for the next
year around two million dollars so more
than enough to support themselves
possibly not in the lifestyle that
they're accustomed to yes Prince Harry
and Megan marques post royal lifestyle
is already changing et have learned that
Megan and Harry are tightening their
purse strings by cutting their roughly
15 member staff as far as this goes
there really was no other option
according to our royal source the Sussex
his staff was given notice several weeks
ago
we're told that exceptions were made for
a few beloved staffers who have been
with the palace for years they'll be
reassigned within the royal household
and paid redundancy fees which are
basically severance packages if they
choose to stay on but our source says
Harry and Megan may only retain one to
two staff members themselves according
to our source Megan and Harry's staff
members were shocked by the news
especially after their hard work
discretion and intense loyalties
this was all about being financially
independent the only way to become
financially independent for them was to
leave the royal family now they need to
make a living and get this et has
learned that the reason for these cuts
is because the royal family will no
longer pay for the couple's staff quote
in their new life things will be
streamlined and leaner with staff
located closer to them helps you
understand what did it come to and I
would set my family back from all I have
ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
our source adds that this move also
indicates that Megan in Harry plan to
spend the majority of their time in
North America
MAGIX it's pretty amazing
and I have the two best guys in the
world so I'm
Perry joined Meaghan in their 8 month
old son Archie in Canada on January 21st
after remaining behind in the UK to
finalize the terms of their royal exit I
can only imagine what you may have the
perhaps read of the past few weeks and
the Sussex is haven't wasted any time
since last week Harry and Megan attended
the JPMorgan summit in Miami where they
rubbed elbows with Jennifer Lopez and
Alex Rodriguez and Harry spoke now we're
learning that the couple also visited
Stanford University on Tuesday for
brainstorming meetings with professors
regarding their new charitable
organization we don't have any specifics
on the project but we do know that the
Sussex is blue from Canada to California
on a commercial plane
[Music]